from Beyonce to Shay Mitchell Jessica  Alba rang in 36 with a star-studded  birthday celebration  [Music]  happy 36th birthday Jessica Alba  [Applause]  the actress celebrated her special day  with a prince versus Michael themed  birthday bash at Delilah in Los Angeles  on Friday and it was a big night out for  Hollywood's a-listers Nicole Richie  Kelly Rowland Shay Mitchell and even  pregnant Beyonce were in attendance  lastly the birthday girl stunned in this  sexy cleavage baring black jumpsuit  sheer jacket and fishnet gloves her hair  wild and totally 90s while her hubby  Kash Warren donned a total prints  inspired get up in this leopard print  sequined suit and top hat oh my goodness  just as famous friends singer a happy  birthday and dance the night away  [Applause]  [Music]  you